flutter a UI framework for building apps
on iOS Android the web and desktop at
its core flutter combines a high
performance graphics engine with the
dart programming language in development
dart provides full type safety and
stateful hot reload to help you build
reliable apps quickly in production dart
compiles to native machine code which
means your graphics will render
beautifully on any platform install
flutter then run flutter create to
create a new project now open the main
dart file this is where you build your
app the UI is laid out as a tree of
widgets and the framework provides
hundreds of pre-built widgets to handle
things like animations scrolling
responsive layout and more you can build
your own widget by extending the
stateless widget class you then define
your UI by overriding its build method
now it's important to understand that
everything in flutter is a widget this
method returns a widget and it's
children return widgets and their
children return widgets giving us an
expressive declarative UI structure
which you can easily Traverse using
flutters awesome tool whenever the input
data to this widget changes flutter will
rebuild the UI by calling your build
method stateless widgets are immutable
and don't have any internal data when
you have an interactive widgets where
the internal data might change based on
user input you can extend a stateful
widget properties defined on this class
can be reactive for example we might
have a counter that starts at zero then
in our build method we have one of
flutters built-in buttons that cause a
function whenever it's pressed it
increments the counter by coin set state
which tells the framework that the
widgets data has changed causing the UI
to re-render with the latest data you
can now play with this app on a real
device using the flutter run command
that's cool and all but let's make some
changes we'll go back to our source code
and Center the button on the middle of
the screen instead of writing code just
click on the button and hit control
shift R then wrap your button with a
center widget next change the color of
the button and notice how flutter
previews that color directly in your IDE
now too hot reload the app simply type
or into the command line it only took a
few milliseconds to build a new version
of our app and notice how the state of
the counter was unchanged that's what I
like to call an awesome developer
experience this has been flutter in 100
seconds if you want to learn more check
out my newly updated flutter fire based
course on fire ship i/o thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one
you